when I was living in my camper trailer
um I'm living in there with a man you're
living here by yourself by myself oh
dang yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you have a
security item yeah oh so long story
short
um there was a guy from Baskin who
wanted to move to Nashville and do music
and he ended up becoming a songwriter
producer and had some success like
in the 90s okay but he wanted to move in
the late 70s and uh my grandfather on my
daddy side he gave him just like a few
hundred dollars to kind of help him move
to Nashville and get started so as a
favor in return well he was my mentor
kind of growing up he'd stop by my house
whenever he came home to Baskin and
stuff and okay
um
he let me live in his Studio parking lot
out in Bellevue
for free for three years so I hooked up
the trailer to the water the Wi-Fi the
electricity I mean I flooded the thing I
was having uh
Plumbing issues and nobody wanted to
help me work on the thing so you know
I've got my daddy on the other line and
he's like we'll do this close off your
valves fill up your tank then you know
let it run for a while undo it and let
it kind of flush out while I fell asleep
and
the entire dining camper trailer flooded
it's uh I mean the floor eventually
started rotting out you know you just
had to be careful where you were
stepping yeah jump over the other part
to get to the bathroom you know oh yeah
it's like Dance Dance Revolution kind of
in there at a certain point you know
especially in a bad trailer don't when
they start to go they start that's right
yeah I mean the whole thing needed to be
redone and
um I remember one time I was I was
taking a shower and um I had just
started these like
kickboxing lessons or it was some
something called hot box here in town
where it's like super hot but you're
boxing and um
you know what it is you've been there I
mean I used to I've been super high in a
very small yeah yeah you know what hot
boxing is like the other hot box yeah
and I've not been able to get out so
yeah I've freaked out before one time in
a truck and yeah almost kicked my way
out of a window of a well Ranger yeah
well that's the way I felt because how a
camper trailer shower doors are they've
got the little latch on it so you can
close it when you're traveling it's not
like flinging open and I remember I was
sitting there showering and it was ankle
deep water my propane was running out so
the water was cold my shower head fell
off I'm showering with a water hose and
then I'm like you know what this is some
[__] but whatever so I try to you know
I'm just like I'm gonna get out of the
shower and it's gonna be a better day I
get to go you know push on that door
that dang latch it closed no I was stuck
in there but you know what them
kickboxing lessons came in handy because
I wow right out wow God dang
oh put that cheek in there Boo get that
leopard leg I did I sure did uh-huh
don't mess with me my sister I live in a
trailer for a long time and she was so
funny because like a branch fell in
their trailer right in Louisiana she
live out in Gonzales and she had such a
positive attitude like one day she sends
me a picture there's a branch through
their kitchen right through the kitchen
and like one of her kids is like sitting
on the other side of the counters eating
cereal like they're just so kind of nice
just like right and there's a bird on
the branch and she goes look Theo look
how beautiful right and like
I like I wish my perception of the world
was like how beautiful right look at
this bird in our home right like look
how cool wow honestly I feel like I just
learned a lot from that story right
there yeah I mean seeing the good you
got to see the good and everything yeah
she had the good going on
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one